Hijab, you absolute coward.
>> [music]
[music]
[singing]
>> You know, I get it. I I I I understand
the embarrassment. I understand the
humiliation. I understand you wanting to
hide because of what has happened to you
as a narcissist. You know, you can't
believe that this has but just been done
to you by someone
as unqualified as I am. You know, you
with your six degrees, with your
education, with you knowing multiple
languages, able to speak the Arabic and
having access to all of the tafsir and
the commentary and the exegetes.
There's no way that this could have
happened to you.
Right? The overwhelming,
vast majority of Muslim scholars from
the classical period until now believe
that this Bible that we have in our
hands Show me that.
>> show corruption.
>> Show me that. Don't just say that. I
don't have the reference of that.
>> Show me that.
Brother, you you can't be making I'll
show you. I don't want to show you. I
don't want to You mean you got all those
books behind you and you don't got a a
reference? You don't got the source that
you can show us? I can't right now. I'm
drinking my tea. I'm sitting down. You
can find it. This is uncontroversial,
Avery.
>> Okay, let me show you why this is
controversial.
>> that I know there are some scholars who
didn't believe that. I know
Yeah, I know that. I'm loving your
honesty. So, there's some scholars who
believe in textual corruption and there
are some scholars who believe in
wholesale preservation.
>> That's beautiful. Good job Good job
admitting that.
>> some scholars of Islam might have
believed in this. I'm not negating this
point. That the Jews and Christians at
the time of the prophet had some kind of
preserved text.
>> So, then So, this means that our
position is completely Islamic that the
scriptures are uncorrupted.
I mean there there there's just no way.
There there's no way that someone as
unqualified as myself, someone who does
not speak multiple languages, someone
who does not have access to the
scholarly exegetes and the tafsir and
the asbab al-nuzul, there's there's no
way someone like me can be more
knowledgeable on the Islamic subjects
than you.
Right? What does Furqan mean? What does
Furqan mean?
>> Furqan means criterion. Okay, so what
does it mean? A standard of truth that
tells you what's right AND WHAT'S WRONG.
WHAT'S WHAT?
THE QURAN SAYS THE TORAH IS AL-FURQAN.
>> [laughter]
>> You want me to get dressed for the
occasion? I'm getting my shirt messy.
Hold on.
Are you okay? Is what's this guy doing?
Is it good get out of here. You want to
throw [music] the towel, boy? I need to
dress for the occasion, man.
This isn't happening.
There there's no way that this
this uneducated
uh
young, black, tall, dark, extremely
handsome young man knows more about my
religion than me. The I I've debated the
best. I've I could speak Arabic. I I I
know the subject, but this He He He's
coming and he's outclassing me in every
single topic and reference that I'm
bringing up to him.
This can't be happening.
Is what's going on in your head, isn't
it? The Quran is al-muhaimin. It's
called al-muhaimin.
>> Would you like to see interpreters that
say otherwise? That say Muhammad is the
muhaimin?
No, no, no. Some of your scholars, they
said Muhammad is the muhaimin. You see,
look, you're having to lie now. This is
quite Do you want me to show you? Can I
share my screen?
No, no, no. You don't need to share. You
don't waste What are you laughing at?
Now, check out what Ibn Kathir says
here. All of these people say that what
is [music] guarded over is Muhammad over
the Quran. Oh. So, he said no one SAID
THAT. OH, THAT'S NOT what everyone said.
But, how many people do you count here?
>> One, two, three, four, five. So, Ibn
Kathir, he agrees that yes, Muhammad is
a muhaimin over the Quran, but that's
just not what this verse is saying.
>> Exactly. Add Ibn Kathir to this list of
people who believe that Muhammad is the
muhaimin over the Quran, which according
to Muhammad Hijab, muhaimin corrector,
authority, criterion. So, Muhammad is
the corrector, authority, and criterion
over Allah's uncreated speech?
I know that's tough.
But,
you know, you're trying to figure out
ways to get out of this. You're trying
to figure out how can you How can you
reconcile yourself? How can you pick up
this slack because the damage is done.
My video's blowing yours out of
proportion. I mean, almost 400,000 views
in just uh 2 days. And so, you need to
stop this. You need to get control of
the narrative. So, what do you do? You
give a copyright strike.
You strike the channel like the cowards
before you, like Muslim Lantern before
you, like the Orthodox Muslim,
Flippiano, did to Elijah apologetics.
Shout out to that young brother who
destroyed Flippiano. You are the same
coward. It's the same spirit, just a
different body. And so, despite you
giving verbal confirmation, So, is it
okay that I record this and put it on my
channel? Just want to get a verbal
confirmation. We're good. Well, I mean,
look, you can go live right now. I mean,
I haven't got any issues with that
myself. I'm recording. We're live
already?
Yeah, I'm recording right now. So, I'm
just making sure I can
>> live. Go live so that your people can
see what's happening right now.
>> Oh, they they will. So, I I just want a
verbal confirmation you're not going to
copyright strike me. No, you'll go
you're going to go live and it's
absolutely fine. Okay, cool. You still
go through with the copyright strike.
So, what does this tell us? This tells
us that you're a dog. It tells us that
you're a coward. It tells us that you're
fearful. It tells us that you're
egotistical. You're fragile. You're
soft. You're soft.
You cannot handle someone to out that
can outmatch you. I was better than you
intellectually. I was better than you
rhetorically. You could not stand up to
me in any area of this field. And so,
what do you do? You try to silence. You
try to copyright strike. So, for all of
you guys following this, we did a post
on Twitter where you can go ahead and
help tag team YouTube to get them get
some human eyes on this matter so that
they can rectify this and solve this
fraudulent copyright claim from this
demon. And this will be a fun fun
victory to continue to celebrate in the
face of the dawagandists, the dawa
kittens, as the weeks go by. All glory
to our father,
the son, and the Holy Spirit.
Man, you're making this stuff worse for
yourself. This right here
is the worst move you could have made at
[music] this point in time. You should
have just taken the L.
Should have just taken the L.
>> [music]
[music]
[singing]
>> Don't cry, Habib. I won't set a trap for
you. You walked yourself into the truth
without me having to. My guy's the big
G, so spell it with a capital. You ain't
walking in the spirit. You a casual. How
can you compare [music and singing] us?
You don't think outside your box. Think
you think about a lot and think I'm
brilliant or not. Think you're free in
your religion, but your spirit's in a
knot. [singing] Sorry about it. I don't
care if you be feeling it or [music]